personne n'est à l'abri d'une maladie
mentale et on peut se dire qu'en maladie
mentale n'a pas de code postal
il ya une semaine la disparition du juge
de la cour suprême clément gascon a
causé vraiment les mois partout au pays
il a heureusement été retrouvé sain et
sauf quelques heures plus tard
et hier le juge gascon a causé un autre
mois celui la cre est positif il a
dévoilé publiquement par communiqué
qu'il vivait avec des problèmes de santé
mentale
un acte de transparence que plusieurs
salut sur les réseaux sociaux depuis les
24 dernières heures c'est presque une
déferlante d'appui pour le juge gascon
je vais vous donner quelques extraits de
la déclaration du juge cette déclaration
vous a échappé
il écrit depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années je conjugue avec une maladie
parfois sur noise la dépression et les
troubles de l'anxiété c'est une maladie
qui se soigne se traite ce contrôle
certains jours mieux que d'autres et
ensuite sur sa disparition il dit je ne
peux ni expliquer et justifier ce que je
comprends à être une crise de panique et
j'exprime mes profonds regrets envers
tous ceux et celles qui en ont durement
fait les frais j'accueille docteur
marième coton lé psychiatre à l'institut
universitaire en santé mentale de
montréal qui a aussi publié un livre
quelques années l'année dernière je
pense pivot de 2 ans et vous avez
souvent parlé de la stigmatisation dans
les conférences et dans d'autres
circonstances notre coton évidemment ce
geste lors de
juge gascon est un geste courageux geste
qu'il doit exiger beaucoup de lui
absolument parce que ça a l'air ce même
si les avancées dans les dernières
années sur l'ouverture que la population
des monts travers les troubles de santé
mentale
il reste encore beaucoup de maîtres de
ce tri méditation et de tabous à ce
sujet là donc pour une personne qui
aurait un métier en partie public
d'assumer ouvertement dire bordjis j'ai
ce problème le jeu me traite j'ai des
traitements pour ça effectivement ça
demande courage il peut y avoir une
certaine pensée magique entourant les
gens qui connaissent pas la maladie
mentale de dieu ben ça devrait soigner
ça devrait se régler comme ça le juge
gascon il nous manque quelque chose qui
est assez frappant et je conjugue avec
cette maladie depuis tellement longtemps
qu'est-ce que ça envoie comme message
mais qu'elle se traite aussi absolument
c'est sûr que dans la vase mental c'est
très basse au son par des troubles
d'anxiété de dépression comme il est
fait mention
il ya des gens qui ont des épisodes
unique de ces troubles
et pour beaucoup de gens ce sont des
maladies intermittente dont qui vaut
qu'ils vont être symptomatique de façon
intermittente dans leur vie par moments
les symptômes peuvent peuvent revenir
quand ils vivent des choses difficiles
dans leur vie par exemple et symptômes
peuvent revenir si effectivement y ont
arrêté leur médication pendant un
certain temps ce qu'il semble prête son
corps donc il ya dire qu'il ya des
facteurs comme ça mais ce n'est pas rare
que des troubles anxieux et dépressifs
s'échelonnent comme ce sont des longues
années que pour certaines personnes
c'est le combat d'une vie
le combat d'une vie on n'allait pas
qu'on inverse danse parler bien sûr
général dallaire qui souffrait d'un
syndrome post traumatique puis on a même
parlé même de suicides dans son cahier
des artistes ça ceci est belle pour la
cause
il reste lui évoqué aussi une crise de
panique huit associés aussi un
changement de médication à ceci ou c'est
des décisions professionnelles
importantes
alors si c'est vrai public c'est son nom
assez sournois cette maladie d'
absolument les attaques de panique
peuvent survenir abandonné abruptement
et une attaque de panique c'est très
très très invalidants sata que les gens
souvent vont avoir des symptômes
physiques qui vont être à bout de
souffle il voir dans le car qui va
palpiter dans les mains et pourquoi pas
mourir ils viennent souvent l'urgence
disant faire crise de car dans ces
moments là donc c'est ce que sera cette
période là quelqu'un peut difficilement
fonctionné durant une attaque de panique
ça se traite ça se contrôle donc c'est
sûr qu'il va y avoir des ajustements le
fait dans son traitement la lumière de
cet événement là effectivement une
attaque de panique ça peut survenir
comme ça spontanément que c'est
extrêmement comment évaluez vous la
description qu'en fait le juge gascon et
ça me prend très complet - s'assemblent
quelqu'un qui est capable de voir et de
non seulement la vive la sentir la subir
sa maladie mais d'être capable de bien
la contrôler et de serait ce que par les
mots qui lui donne oui tout à fait c'est
quelqu'un que je trouve qu'il quitterait
assumer dans sa déclaration dont qui
porte vraiment cette déclaration le et
qui ça paraît dans sa façon de parler
aussi que ça fait des années qu'ils
combo ce qui à ce problème le don qu'il
est habituellement 30 sujet avec son
médecin ses proches pour mâconnais sa
maladie parce que bon proche avec
seulement ont confisqué donc c'est
quelqu'un qui est habitué à essayer de
contrôler le plus possible ses symptômes
et effectivement ça parlait d'enfants
jusqu'où et quel est le régime de la
dépression ou des troubles anxieux ou de
crises de panique je m'en parle pas du
jusqu'à ce qu'on connaît pas son corps
mais en général c'est multifactoriel et
on ne connaît pas l'ensemble des causes
qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya une petite
prédisposition familiale se dote les
gens qui ont des troubles de l'humeur et
des troubles anxieux dans leurs familles
ont un risque augmenté que les d'en
avoir une partie ready terre mais ça
n'explique pas tout souvent ce qu'on va
dire c'est qu'il peut y avoir des
précipitations cologix a tackle du faux
les épisodes vont survenir après quelque
chose de difficile que les personnes ont
vécu et c'est aussi socialement il ya
des observations à faire c'est à dire
que c'est une maladie qui est en hausse
l'anxiété la dépression dans les
sociétés occidentales donc il peut être
aussi quelque chose dans notre de vie
dans nos valeurs sociétales qui favorise
aussi en essais dont le très stressés on
est stressé construit beaucoup axé sur
la performance
donc c'est tout ça c'est des facteurs
qui peuvent contribuer bien vous vous
envoyer dans tous les milieux mais dans
des milieux où le stress ou les
exigences des professions est encore
plus grand ça doit être encore plus
omniprésent pendant le second c'est que
selon les lits couches sociales sous
économie questrecques vins différents
vivent dans la pauvreté c'est
extrêmement stressant d'une certaine
façon avoir des postes monsieur un jeu
c'est un emplois stressants et des
décisions à manger aussi à l'apprendre
lui le stress va vivre plus de cette
fois être vécu plus de cette façon juge
en chef ont réagi immédiatement hier
après midi
c'est vraiment inédit pour eux mes
collègues et moi sommes extrêmement
fiers du jusqu'à ce qu'on qui à mon
point d'appui toute ma confiance je suis
impatient de le voir siéger à nouveau à
nos côtés cette semaine c'est mais c'est
pas invalidant sur le plan professionnel
lorsque c'est bien soigné c'est bien
traités ont nécessairement donc c'est ce
que j'imagine qu'il ya vu son médecin il
a été quelque chose de nelly mais non ça
veut pas dire que ça altère le jugement
des gens et ça je trouvais aussi que
c'est une réaction que j'ai trouvé assez
touchant parce que ça montre l appui
d'un employeur ou l'autre camp fin d'un
employant si on peut dire par rapport à
son à son âme professionnelle que ce
problème là ce que les gens craignent
beaucoup de ne pas être supporté par
laurent
il est fait de ça c'est intéressant
parce que c'était extrêmement positif au
fond absolument ça montre qu'il est mais
s'il ya des gens qui peuvent parfois
être soutenant par rapport à ça est ce
que je trouve de très positif aussi
c'est que c'est le juge en question est
un homme donc les hommes consultent
moins pour la dépression ils vont au
moins chercher de l'aide professionnelle
que les femmes significativement ses
invoqué comme une des raisons qui fait
en sorte qu'ils se suicident trois fois
plus que les femmes ont pour briser le
tabou qui peut être encore plus fort sur
les hommes qui sont encore parfois avec
aux prises avec des valeurs un esprit
traditionnel ou s'accordent pas le droit
d'avoir des problèmes ça compte pas le
droit de pouvoir demander de l'aide mais
l'honneur un professionnel qui admet
publiquement de façon très assumé j'ai
des problèmes de santé mentale
je prends des médicaments j'ai un
traitement suivi pour ça je trouve que
ça aide pour que les gens comprennent
que ça peut arriver à n'importe qui me
sont mous femme n'arrive pas seulement
mal parce qu'ils parlent d'une vingtaine
d'années je crois que ça arrive à tout
âge ça arrive à tout âge absolument
c'est il ya déjà il peut y avoir des cas
parfois tu commences à l'adolescence et
des fois il ya des cas qui commence dans
le troisième âge est ce que c'est le
cadet il faut prendre son mal en
patience a dit klaus se soigne il dit
c'est un modèle ou six exemplaires de
dire ben ça se soigne ça se traite je
pense somme c'est quand même quelqu'un
qui est fait par exemple une carrière
extraordinaire malgré ce trou bleu parce
qu'il le combat su parce qu'il ya eu des
traitements donc ouais c'est aussi
peut-être porteur d'espoir de dire parce
qu'on a une maladie mentale qu'on peut
pour réaliser des projets donc c'est
important de
de de lever le stigmate qui est peut
être la maladie mentale mais on a une on
va changer rapidement de sujet parce
qu'on a appris bilan absolument
hallucinant ce nom drame attire
aujourd'hui les membres liés à la
canicule sur les 60 iman relie à la
canicule l'été dernier ou à montréal il
y en avait 17 qui souffrait de
schizophrénie
expliquez-nous rapidement le lien entre
la schizophrénie et la canicule ou la
capacité prend soin soir oui il y en a
trois en fait que les symptômes de la
schizophrénie qui peuvent empêcher
légende de prendre soin d'eux durant la
canicule donc ils peuvent comme lyon
difficultés d'organisation par exemple
peuvent moins souvent penser à boire de
l'eau en une douche il ya aussi des
facteurs environnementaux parce que
c'est en général parce que tout finisse
maladie sévère qui pour la majorité des
gens empêche de travailler
donc c'est des gens qui se retrouvent
dans des couches socio économique plutôt
basse ils ont tendance à habiter dans
des logements non non climatisé très peu
aérée dans des parties du centre-ville
qui sont les plus chaudes aussi parce
que moins de 10 euros ils sont pauvres
et puis ils n'ont pas toujours les
moyens d'aller de prendre le transport
pour aller au centre d'achat par exemple
au lieu de la climatisation
il ya aussi la schizophrénie chez les
schizophrènes on remarque que les
mécanismes physiologiques pour contrôler
la la chaleur du corps sont aussi
déficient
donc ça joue également il ya des gens
qui à cause de leurs symptômes aussi
n'osent pas sortir de chez eux parce
qu'ils sont par un oeil et d'où ils ont
peur de quelque chose à l'extérieur dont
qui vont rester enfermés à la à
l'intérieur sans climatisation sans
aération
donc c'est une population vulnérable tu
reve nir am en regard de la canicule et
aussi les antipsychotiques qui prennent
qui peuvent aussi interférer avec la
capacité du corps de gérer la chaleur et
d'évacuer la chaleur donc leur
traitement aussi paiement contribué pour
que plusieurs dimensions donc c'est
vraiment gros pain risque qu'il faut
encadrer et protégé durant la canicule
une bougie en fait sur une surveillant
merial coton tout était absolument
passionnant merci beaucoup de plaisir